et on va plus loin avec vienne l'imam
directeur du mensuel afrique magazine
dont josiane le soir et face à vous
bruno daroux de la rédaction de france
24 bonjour brunoh bonjour rafale
consultation à l'elysée aujourd'hui
c'est une figure originale sous la vème
république à l'image de la configuration
inédite issue des urnes dimanche une
assemblée ingouvernable la
représentation nationale éclatée en de
multiples chapelles et au milieu un
président qui tourne de composer les
contours d'une future majorité en
recevant les chefs de partis aujourd'hui
et demain écoutez le conseil qui a donné
au chef de l'état françois bayrou le
président du modem composante de la
coalition présidentielle ensemble avec
ses 46 députés
j'ai dit s'approcher le plus près
possible de l'union décéda le plus près
possible
je n'ai pas dit obtenir
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de volontés
disponibles pour l'instant qui
s'expriment peu
parce que ressortir de la séquence
électorale on est dans dans les dents
les affrontement systématique dans le
combat de boxe comme ça
mais au-delà de cela dans la période qui
s'ouvre je suis persuadé qu'il y a des
bonnes volontés disponibles des bonnes
volontés lesquels bruno daroux le futur
gouvernement quel qu'il soit d'ailleurs
devra s'appuyer soit sur une majorité
parlementaire soit sur des coalitions de
projets voilà vous avez tout dit et
lesquels bonnes volontés disponibles
peut être que françois bayrou le sait
mais personne ne le sait vraiment
interrogé sur bfm edouard philippe a dit
à peu près la même chose alors sans
appeler à une union nationale il
appelait la coalition la plus large
possible oui mais alors soit
effectivement saut c'est une vraie
coalition comme ça existe dans d'autres
démocraties européennes on se met
d'accord sur un programme de
gouvernement après tout bon en france on
s'étonne de ce résultat mais qui d'un
point de vue démocratique n'est
peut-être pas si mauvais que ça parce
qu'il est plus représentatif des
différentes tendances sauf que dans les
autres pays européens il ya une vraie
habitudes du compromis mais sur des sur
des points de gouvernement sont lents
forment une vraie coalition visiblement
à l'heure où on se parle on en n'est pas
là est le seul parti qui pourrait faire
coalition avec la majorité
présidentielle
c'est effectivement les républicains
mais d'après ce qu'on entend pour le
moment c'est pas ce qui est prévu donc
on en revient à la coalition de projet
le vote du texte au cas par cas un coup
à droite un coup à gauche on va pas très
bien quand même comment tout cela va
fonctionner alors françois bayrou il dit
il y aura des bonnes volontés donc il y
aura quelques uns qui vont venir mais
enfin on n'est pas dans les situations
1988 où il ne manquait au premier
ministre de l'époque michel rocard que
quatorze députés donc là on pouvait
aller chercher un peu à droite à gauche
selon les textes là il en faut quand
même plus de 40 donc ça paraît quand
même extrêmement compliqué on peut
imaginer peut-être que ce serait des
votes projet par projet avec le vote de
l'essentiel d'un parti sur tel ou tel
texte présente sur les retraites qui
s'annonce déjà comme un des sujets quand
même très très chaude du prochain
quinquennat peut-être que les
républicains ne déciderait pas besoin de
voter ce texte avec des compromis et ses
215 peut-être voir à l'assemblée issue
des urnes dimanche deux cent quarante
cinq députés pour la coalition ensemble
ajoutez à cela les 61 des l'air on
arrive à 306 il aurait là effectivement
le nombre magique on serait au dessus
des 200 cadres pour compléter ces que
les députés aient l'air ils ont quand
même été élu parce que il était non le
président semble exact le même dans
l'opposition emmanuel macron donc faut
quand même faire un et christian jacob
l'a bien compris lui qui pour leur ferme
la porte à une coalition écouter
nous restons dans une position dans dans
le
de manière déterminée déterminé mais mes
responsables jamais on ne saura dans le
blocage des institutions
mêlez pas question de rentrer dans une
logique de patte de coalition de
participation pour quoi que ce soit 7,7
nature 11 il n'a pas d'autre choix qui
élargira la majorité emmanuel macron
mais acquise yade imams dont sérieux
c'était le fun c'est ça le jeu après
tout on n'arrêtait pas de dire que ce
système était un brin peut
manquer de représentativité que ça sur
représentés les majorités
donc là on a une assemblée comme vous
vous disiez qui ressemble à la france
après tout elle est comme ça cette
france il faut faire avec après moi j'ai
tendance à pas trop écouter ce qui se
raconte là depuis 24 heures puisque on
est clairement dans le dans la posture
post électorale on est clairement dans
faire monter les enchères pour voir si a
pas un truc à gagner et puis et les
plaques tectoniques qui bougent dans ce
pays elle continue à bouger vous avez vu
que
l'alliance nuque elle est déjà aux
prises à des problèmes complexes de qui
est ce qu'on est un groupe parce qu'on
n'est pas un groupe est ce qu on est
chacun des groupes séparés et on va très
vite voir dans cette gauche la gauche
sociale-démocrate la gauche écologique
et la gauche radicale se se ce ça veut
dire se se se dissoudre face à des
projets très précis et puis l'autre
point dont je suis assez stupéfait qu'on
en parle assez peu c'est quand même les
89 députés à l'assemblée nationale et
puis tous les jours on découvre que
c'est pas des députés malgré le discours
officiel du rassemblement national sur
la normalisation la des personnages
extrêmement tranchant extrêmement
clément avec des passes et bien chargé à
vous ça vous surprend qu'ils aient percé
le plafond de verre du scrutin
majoritaire uninominal à deux tours à
l'occasion c'est qu'est ce qui s'est
passé en fait c'est que le pacte
républicain a explosé mais il a explosé
partout ça c'est pas juste on a tendance
à vouloir le coller sur le dos de mâcon
mais en fait c'est tous les partis sert
coach avait dit quand il y avait des
duels nuque rassemblement national les
gens de rang sur les gens de 2,2 de la
coalition présidentielle ne sont pas à
les soutenir forcément les nuques écosse
c'était le contraire les nuls sont pas
allés soutenir les gens la république
donc il ya plus de barrages donc ça
finit par représenter et puis il faut
quand même dire qu'on les caricatures
extérieur mais il faut un boulot de il
ya des gens qui sont implantés
localement depuis des années qui petit à
petit et puis et puis encore une fois
l'ambiance détestable du débat politique
depuis plusieurs années en france sur le
racisme sur l'intégration sur le racisme
sur les minorités sur l'islam le zemmour
isme tout ça il y en a plein la télé
depuis des mois et des mois et des mois
et donc que des gens finissent par se
dire on n'a qu'à m on va pas prendre et
moore on va apprendre l'original on va
aller on va les transformer en valais m
députés donc tout ça pour moi et d'une
certaine logique après comment ce régime
qui a été conçue par le général de
gaulle pour éviter la guerre civile pour
éviter la dislocation de la france avec
un président fort et une assemblée plus
ou moins un parlementarisme light cadres
et cadres et d'un seul coup ce tank qui
avait été prévu pour ça il faut qu'ils
se transforment en fiat 500 affaires du
parlementarisme à bouger entre les
lignes et là c'est pas du tout la
culture politique française c'est pas du
tout la culture dans laquelle on vit une
vraie confrontation elle alors oui parce
que ce qui complique quand même les
choses à la différence effective
effectivement quand on regarde ce qui se
passe dans les autres grandes
démocraties européennes cette culture du
compromis elle est l'axé mais ce qui
change en france c'est qu'il ya la
stature du président de la république
qui est libre et 100 et donc en fait les
partis ils hésitent parfois à faire des
compromis parce qu'ils se disent si je
fais un compromis avec le parti
présidentiel ça veut dire aussi que je
me mets sous l'autorité du président que
je lui facilite la tâche voilà où lui
facilite la tâche ce qui n'existe pas
dans les autres démocraties vraiment
parlementaire et qui donc d'un certain
point de vue facilite les choses si on
prend la coalition allemande les partis
actuels n'ont pas vraiment la pression
de servir le plat à olaf scholz là c'est
une coalition vraiment de deux parties
en france c'est vrai que s'accomplit qui
est en surélévation comme ça le
président de la république parce que si
on réalise on quand on leur dit rien les
marrons du feu et comme l'élection farce
élection présidentielle ensuite ça crée
des sacrés des problèmes emmanuel macron
a refusé aujourd'hui la démission
d'elisabeth bornes simple figure de
style via l'imam c'est l'usagé
républicain ou bien c'est un fait
politique elisabeth borne est elle
vraiment assuré de rester à matignon
d'après vous
pour ne rien de râler on en a parlé au
téléphone moi je pense que franchement
il a donné un signe qui est un signe de
présidentialiste faire je les nomme est
lé premier ministre elle reste en poste
elle fait pas partie pour le moment de
la négociation elle fait pas partie de
la discussion est lé premier ministre je
ne vois pas encore une fois peut-être
comme l'art sortira sur twitter je vois
pas la situation change et donc un jour
où nantes 300 il ya un sens politique à
cette annonce je pense qu'il peut pas il
peut pas au sortir d'une élection qui
était déjà très difficile pour son camp
dire ok très bien je prends la démission
on va refaire tout il peut pas que c'est
très difficile faut pas oublier que
comme comme le disait bruno le dans la
vème république le président dans une
situation comme celle là a des pouvoirs
importants dans une situation de
cohabitation ce qui était le cas
je serai à 6 93 4 c'est plus complexe
parce que le premier ministre et chef du
gouvernement mais il ne dépend pas de
son président alors que là le président
dans un jeu comme ça il a les pouvoirs
de la présidence qui sont importants il
ya juste faire aussi nous une autre
raison un peu moins nobles à intervalles
pas beaucoup qui est qui qui fait que
pour le moment ils gardent elisabeth
bornes c'est qu'avant le vote de
confiance à l'assemblée le 5 juillet
donc s'il la vire maintenant si vous
passez l'expression et qui nomme
quelqu'un d'autre et que ce quelqu'un
d'autre se présente le 5 juillet est
désavoué à l'assemblée il va devoir
nommer dont il n'aurait gagné du
possible et donc à mon avis une valeur
il va la gare ils gagnent du temps parce
que il va la garder jusqu'au ce vote de
confiance qui se présente d'ailleurs
dans une situation absolument inédite là
aussi à l'assemblée nationale et si elle
passe la barre eh ben elle sera
peut-être assuré de rester quelques
semaines quelques mois s'ils ne passent
pas la barre valent à elles dégagent et
puis il n'a pas tant de cheval ces choix
sont relativement limités puisque
prendre quelqu'un d'autre c'est un
équilibre instable cette coalition il ya
quand même les ja les modems il ya les
horizons il ya les philippe east qui est
tous ces gens là sont déjà sur 2025 donc
ils sont déjà dans leurs calculs donc
elle l a l'énorme avantage d'être
relativement neutre politiquement et à
sa main prendre quelqu'un d'autre c'est
plus compliqué donc je pense que
franchement même de ce point de vue là
il n'y avait pas de raison de mais en
même temps il a besoin dans la situation
actuelle de aussi de quelqu'un qui sache
faire un peu de la politique ce qui
n'est pas à coup majeur d'elisabeth
olivier olivier ferrand qui avait
survécu au qu'ovide survivra est à la
nouvelle a6 limite
beaucoup depuis deux jours sur les
écrans des chaînes d'information
continue c'est catherine vautrin wii qui
avait failli être fière ministre et qui
aujourd'hui excellent du grand indien le
lr et beaucoup de reims métropole
aujourd'hui mais qui personnifie
romenteau roberge avec avait été mis un
peu de côté et les un petit peu partout
aujourd'hui donc on sent bien que les
leçons sont tirés quand même de ce qui
est un échec de la coalition
présidentielle mais c'est aussi un échec
je pense excusez-moi de la gauche dite
n'eurent justement vendée seul véritable
gagnant et il faut le redire c'est le
rassemblement national on va parler de
la gauche puisque la france insoumise
promet de déposer une motion de censure
vous venez de le dire bruno le 5 juillet
prochain ps et pcf donc parti socialiste
et parti communiste français n'exclut
pas de la voter cette motion de censure
sauf sauf si le gouvernement s'engage à
faire passer leurs réformes écouter les
six dans le discours de politique
générale il ya rien rien rien pour
pouvoir d'achat des français si dans le
discours de politique générale il ya
encore la retraite à 65 ans s'il ya
toutes ces mesures que les français dont
les français ne veulent pas entendre
parler nous voterons contre ce discours
de politique générale est donc apparu à
une motion de censure on vote raconte
voilà c'est que ce soir je lui dirai
qu'il n'a pas à avoir peur du blocage
des institutions parce qu'il n'aurait
pas de majorité parce que si demain il
ya sur la table du parlement la
possibilité d'augmenter le smic tout de
suite de 10 à 15% ce que je propose il y
aura la majorité des députés de gauche
qui voteront cette mesure en tout cas
les communistes la soutiendrons et donc
pas de blocage on peut avancer vers ces
mesures est venu lui dire que le pays
n'est pas bloqué il ya des réformes qui
sont bloqués celle qu'il avait peut-être
proposer manière précipitée mais il ya
une volonté dans ce chez nous d'aller en
avant ce pouvoir d'achat par exemple et
donc si le président est par exemple
disposé à apporter le smic à 1500 euros
il aura une majorité pour cela s'il veut
revaloriser les pensions de retraite à
un niveau qui soit l'équivalent du smic
nous sommes là aussi pour le voter s'il
veut bloquer les prix des produits 3d
nécessité là encore nous répondrons
présents voilà donc un bloc qui pèse
environ 140 députés souhaitent imposer
sa politique joue-t-il la politique du
pire en ce moment là en fait c'est
intéressant quand même là les
déclassements savez roussel et d'olivier
faire ça veut dire qu'on reprend le
moment ils disent alors on est prêts
incompris pour faire avancer le pays
mais pour l'instant à nos conditions
c'était à lisa macron battu reprend le
smic à 1500 euros la retraite au niveau
du smic et puis à ce moment là on vote
mais évidemment c'est une position alors
soit c'est une position qui est bloquée
auquel cas on ira ce sera l'impasse soit
c'est un début de négociation ça veut
dire que ben le smic si négoce des rêves
à trouver un compromis à 1400 euros la
retraite entre 1100 ce que proposait
emmanuel macron et le smic voilà s'il
arrive à trouver des compromis là-dessus
il va peut-être qu'à ce moment là ça
peut passer ce qui créera des problèmes
au sein de la nu parce que pour le coup
je pense pas que la france a soumises
acceptant à fait sur la même position
célina vous y voyez qu une position
maximaliste au contraire en cliquant
compromis de la part de ces de ces deux
dirigeants bah je vous ai dit je pense
que pour les quelques jours qui viennent
c'est le poker absolue c'est je cache ma
carte je vous annonce que j'ai 4 le
joker dans mes mains et il faut plier
faut se plier et je pense que tous ces
gens parlent aussi à leur électorat au
lendemain d'élections ou encore une fois
pour les uns et pour les autres c'est
voilà stupéfiants comme résultat à part
ceux du rat sont en relationnel donc on
est vraiment dans ce jeu là pour le
moment quand on va arriver vers les
vraies décisions et là on parle de
pouvoir d'achat mais il ya des
thématiques qui sont aussi très
importantes le changement climatique
l'énergie la crise énergétique qui se
profile pour l'hiver prochain avec les
russes qui ferme le gaz partout où la
guerre en kryte et avec la france a
soumises qui veut fermer des centrales
avec les airs ce mythe qui veut fermer
des centrales nucléaires les cadeaux les
autres qui veulent pas les fermer donc
tout ça céline qu'on est là aujourd'hui
elles vont encore bouger le problème
c'est qu'il ya plus une majorité pour
dire on va par là dans un pays qui est
confronté à des vrais défis intérieurs
et extérieurs kiss kiss kill team qui
vont pas attendre cinq ans que ça ce
décompte et qu'on ait un nouveau
président en extérieur tout l'enjeu la
france c'est ça c'est de trouver cet
équilibre là dont on n'a pas l'habitude
c'est pas dans notre histoire c'est pas
dans notre culture politique c'est pas
du tout la manière dont on fonctionne
vous avez vu la campagne on n'a pas
parlé de thèmes on sait juste invectivé
pendant un certains nombres de jours on
a pas on n'a pas discuté sur le fond a
parlé les totems retraite smic et 1500
hawks mais sinon on n'a pas discuté sur
le fond et il ya une autre à nous de
scénario favori n'a beaucoup l'a61 mais
il ya un autre scénario qu'on n'a pas
évoqué en fait et c'est peut-être pour
ça qu'il a reçu les chefs de partis
d'abord ce peut être pour gagner du
temps puisque après il s'envole pour une
séquence diplomatique quand même qui va
faire qu'il n'est pas là de mercredi ce
mercredi jusqu'à mercredi prochain
conseil européen g7 autant sauver des
océans on le voit pas pendant une
semaine il est sur la scène diplomatique
donc il faut qu'ils gagnent du temps il
ay lassé de la posture un peu et reçoit
les chefs de parti mais visiblement ils
parleraient parce que en fait pour le
moment pour pour laisser ces oppositions
sauf peut-être quelques débauchages
individuels mais ils peuvent pas voter
avec la majorité présidentielle mais ils
peuvent s'abstenir
donc en fait une espèce de négociation à
l'abstention et si vous avez fait pas
moins des socialistes les communistes
elle est requis qui s'abstiennent ébats
ce moment là la majorité la majorité
relative elle devient une majorité bien
sûr exprimé après je lui permet faire
passer des textes on va apprendre plein
de choses sur le parlementarisme voilà
les issues merci beaucoup en tout cas
zia lima merci à vous bruno daroux
c'était on va plus loin on se retrouve
dans trois minutes pour un nouveau
journal resterai avec tous dans paris